[Música]
cuando tenía 16 años me diagnosticaron
un trastorno sexual
es la primera vez que digo esto en
público esto sucedió porque llevé una
revista a la escuela con la intención de
fotografía fotocopiar unas imágenes que
me habían gustado para un proyecto
artístico y me la casaron y terminó en
la oficina de la dirección y entonces
hubo un pequeño gran detalle que yo
jamás considere y que fue que estas
imágenes aunque no eran explícitas
sexualmente pues acompañaban un texto
sobre cómo hacerle sexo oral a una mujer
esto fue alarmante para las monjas en mi
escuela y también para mis maestras que
decidieron mandarme a una especie de
terapia con la psicóloga para determinar
si era urgente avisarle o no a mi mamá
sobre mi condición
pase una hora con la psicóloga de la
escuela escuchando la decirme que yo era
una pervertida y puede ser que por
varios años sí me lo haya creído y no sé
hasta que un día pensé que no era cierto
que lo que estaba mal no era yo sino lo
perverso había sido precisamente esa
experiencia porque pues porque existe
esta idea de que tener un cuerpo y
disfrutar de tu sexualidad es algo malo
y esta idea no es algo nuevo y no es
algo que nosotras estamos inventando o
proponiendo en este lugar por primera
vez sino que existe desde los tiempos de
platón él en su discurso filosófico
decía que todos los seres humanos
estamos divididos en dos en cabeza y
cuerpo siendo la cabeza la poseedora de
la virtud y la prudencia y el cuerpo
siendo el vehículo que solo busca el
placer y que te aleja de la iluminación
después la biblia retomó estas ideas
desde una perspectiva de género diciendo
que adam es la cabeza que es justo el
representante de la virtud y la
prudencia
es la representación del cuerpo es decir
la tentación y el pecado esto dictó
desde el pecado original que nuestros
cuerpos son peligrosos y podríamos pasar
el resto del día revisando ejemplos a lo
largo de la historia sobre cómo este
discurso se ha estado repitiendo pero ni
vamos a acabar y además no podemos hacer
nada para cambiar el pasado y es 2018 y
aún seguimos hablando de nuestros
cuerpos y nuestra sexualidad como si
fueran un tabú que es un tabú es algo
prohibido o mal visto por la sociedad
y cómo se manifiesta ese tabú hoy en día
pues cuando fue la última vez que vieron
un niño o una niña dibujando vaginas
o cuántas personas de hecho creen que
podrían dibujar un clítoris
ningún humano así se ven para que sepan
bueno un tabú hace que cuando escuchas
la palabra vagina como se siente a
querer verdad por qué por qué páginas
nos dan vergüenza la vergüenza es una
forma de opresión la vergüenza es
peligrosa porque cuando tienes vergüenza
hace que no te valoras y cuando no te
valoras cds tu poder como cedemos poder
pues en muchas situaciones es muy normal
en cual no nos damos cuenta de lo que
está pasando por ejemplo pase en una
cita con una persona te invitan todo y
terminas cogiendo aunque no realmente
querías
no insistes en usar un condón
qué es lo que el implícito que es el
implícito de esas situaciones es que los
sentimientos momentáneos de esa persona
valen más que tu tiempo y salud tus dos
cosas más valiosas en la vida
o qué tal que si quería escoger están
bajando y se están calentando las cosas
y se te mete la mano a los pantalones
que dices dice sí a huevo vamos no dice
sí no
por qué por qué decimos dije nada porque
quieres que esta persona no sabe que
quieres tener sexo porque porque estamos
actuando informados con ese arcaica y
ridícula idea de la feminidad ideal
siendo la virgen asexual es ridículo
bueno qué tal que ya dijiste que sí pero
empiezan y esta persona no saben que
están haciendo y pues te está lastimando
cuántas veces has aguantado hasta que te
dolió el día después
porque no pudiste decir a la izquierda
para la vergüenza y no solo no hablamos
de estas cosas con nuestras parejas sino
que en realidad no hablamos de estas
cosas con nadie no las platicamos con
nuestras [ __ ] no hablamos con
nuestras hermanas jamás llegamos con
nuestras amigas así de oye tengo comezón
tengo la vulva irritada y entonces
preferimos quedarnos calladas y sentir
angustia y ansiedad porque pensamos que
a lo mejor tenemos algo muy grave cuando
en realidad pudo hacer algo muy común
que pudo ser prevenido y además es esta
misma razón la vergüenza la que nos
impide de ir al doctor y mientras esta
situación sucede allá afuera hay
personas que se están haciendo
millonarias con nuestra vergüenza y nos
están vendiendo productos que nos hacen
creer que necesitamos pero en realidad
nos están haciendo mucho daño por
ejemplo hace un par de años me acuerdo
que vi un comercial en la televisión
sobre duchas vaginales dirigido a
latinoamérica
y para empezar el comercial estaba
protagonizado por una chica rubia
delgada que está en un hotel de lujo en
bikini y se mete a la alberca no el
comercial lo que dice es que si quieres
verte tan fresca como ella pues tienes
que usar este jabón íntimo y el mensaje
implícito de este comercial es que tu
cuerpo huele mal y necesitas hacer algo
al respecto pero qué pasa cuando usas
una ducha vaginal pues te vuelves más
propensa a tener infecciones y eso sí
hace que huela mal y luego porque no
sabemos estas cosas pues porque cuando
estamos en la escuela la educación
sexual que nos dan es de pésima calidad
y casi siempre está enfocada en la
abstinencia o en la reproducción y
entonces qué hacemos cuando no sabemos
algo
y google verdad bueno tuve una pequeña
discusión hace casi dos años con un ex
novio sobre
si todas las mujeres pueden ayudar
en igoogle pero lo que encontré
fue pseudociencia y tonterías mucha
información que se contradecía y como
soy periodista me clavo mucho en la
calidad de la información y me metí en
unos periódicos médicos y pasaron dos
cosas primero no entendía nada
no sabía las partes que mencionaron no
sabía dónde estaban en mi cuerpo que
hacían
donde estaba mi vejiga y me di cuenta
que realmente no sabía mucho sobre mi
propio cuerpo y segundo pues leí que no
saben porque no han estudiado la
anatomía del placer femenino a que hayan
aunque hayan explorado el espacio
y también leí unas cosas muy
interesantes como que no hay dos tipos
de orgasmos solo hay uno y pues muchas
cosas que pensé que todas las mujeres
que conozco quisieran saber
y pensé esto es un problema es un
problema que la información que están en
internet sobre nuestros cuerpos está de
mala calidad y que la poca información
que haya esté muy inaccesible a la
mayoría de la gente y pensé que como la
mayoría de mi trabajo tiene que ver con
simplificar conceptos yo podría hacer
algo al respecto
pero sabía que no iba a poder hacerlo
sola y la llamé a mi amiga pervertida
amaría
pues creo que esa soy yo la razón por la
que soy me busco es porque yo paso todos
mis días dibujando mujeres desnudas soy
artista visual y desde hace unos años mi
trabajo ha girado en torno a la
representación del cuerpo femenino
porque pues me interesa precisamente
revelar nuestros cuerpos como algo bello
y gozoso y más poético y menos
sexualizado que como siempre estamos
acostumbrados a verlos y entonces
platicando con psoe sobre esta
problemática pues decidimos unir las
cosas que sabemos hacer mejor y se nos
ocurrió crear pus y pedja punto net push
y pedja es estamos trabajando en crear
una plataforma en línea bilingüe
gratuita e inclusiva sobre las push it
que va a ser un portal con información
rigurosamente certificada
y además va a contar con un modelo
tridimensional del cuerpo femenino que
vas a poder explorar 360 grados y por
leyes para que por fin puedas entender
en dónde está tu vejiga y cada parte de
tu organismo y cómo funciona
y porque puse y no vagina
bueno pues porque estamos intentando
reapropiarnos de la palabra pus y por
qué vagina sólo se refiere al canal
vaginal que es sólo una parte de nuestro
organismo cuando en realidad el sistema
es mucho más complejo además porque
vagina proviene de la palabra vaina que
significa la funda donde guardas una
espada y nosotras no creemos que
nuestras vaginas existan como un objeto
de servicio a los penes y además porque
queríamos darle una definición extendida
a la palabra pus y para precisamente
incluir a toda esta diversidad de
identidades y de expresiones anatómicas
que existen porque nuestro principal
objetivo con pus y pedja es liberar a
todos los cuerpos marginados pus y pedja
es un ejemplo de un problema que vimos y
decidimos solucionar nosotras mismas
porque podemos
y de eso se trata o sea hoy en día el
mundo está de miedo a mí me da miedo es
muy fácil sentirnos impotentes
pero no somos impotentes
hay algo que podemos hacer que de hecho
es mucho más fácil que construir push y
pedja lo cual es decidir juntos como la
sociedad dejar de en forzar ese tabú
sobre la pussy y para las personas con
push is nos toca a valorarnos
puedes soltar la vergüenza la decisión
es tuya no gracias
[Aplausos]